well Sahar aiz is a professor and
director of the center for security race
and rights at rutka University's law
school she joins us now live from Newark
New Jersey in the United States good to
have you with us so it's not only in
Israel is it that there have been
complaints about censorship of pro
Palestinian voices uh Shadow Banning has
become an issue hundreds of
complaints um by users of social media
since October talking about Shadow
Banning on Facebook Instagram YouTube
you name it right this is this is an
issue going on
worldwide yes in the United States much
of the censorship against people who are
seeking to defend the human rights of
Palestinians or seeking to criticize the
state of Israel especially their
militaries actions in razza um alleging
or describing it as either genocidal or
at the very least multiple war crimes of
ethnic cleansing um Collective
punishment starvation dehydration and
those individuals are often censored in
universities they're often fired from
their
workplaces and they're often
experiencing um various forms of
censorship even in their own private
lives what we're not seeing as much of
yet is the US government uh censoring
them except that we've seen in Congress
just recently resolutions that
incorrectly conflate or Define
anti-Semitism with anti-zionism as an
explicit attempt to censor and
criminalize any criticism of the state
of Israel uh and also of course we're
seeing censorship on social media but
that is controlled primarily by private
companies Facebook uh Twitter and other
social media companies what is it that
social media uses can do when as I said
some of this is taking place not so
overtly u a case in point a Belgian
filmmaker Thomas Madden noticing sudden
decrease in engagement with his with a
Tik Tok video he' posted and you're not
always
notified it's it's a an algorithm we're
told that will suppress engagement and
you might not even know
it yeah well I just want to emphasize
that in the United States there's two
types of censorship and the most visible
high-profile and can be even the most
harmful to people's uh material lives
their work their ability to be in school
and also their ability to be safe has
been in the physical real world where
students and private individuals workers
are getting doxed they're getting
assaulted they're being disciplined in
schools uh universities and often times
uh assaulted when they protest and in
some cases even government agencies
whether it's state local or federal are
trying to either stop them from
protesting altogether or really restrain
them so that that is very real and has
become a means of silencing the mass
movement that has been growing in the
United States and it's unprecedented
because the United States media and the
government has been explicitly
pro-israeli and anti- Palestinian now
when it comes to the social media it's
really based on the analytics and it's
resp every individual or user has Bears
the burden of trying to determine
whether their posts are actually being
viewed and also whether they're being
deleted but again there's very little
legal remedy because it's a private
company it's not State action and the
First Amendment does not apply to
private companies so it's difficult to
to get them to to stop if the public
relations is actually in support of
censorship of Palestinians and I just
want to know one other really important
fact is most most of the people who are
censored are Muslims Arabs South Asians
Palestinians and so there is an issue of
racism and discrimination that's going
on and we talk about this in our report
presumptively anti-semitic islamophobic
tropes in the Palestine Israel discourse
uh that we published with the center for
security race and rights and it shows
very clearly that people private
companies the government the teachers
employers believe that they're justified
in censoring Muslims Arabs in South Asia
because they believe that they're
anti-semitic they believe that Islam and
Muslims teaches people to hate Jews
which is false and so they want to
reframe the issue from a political issue
from a dispute over land and
displacement and war crimes to a
religious holy war and that is not what
the vast majority of advocates for human
rights in pal in Palestine uh believe
the issue to be and as you're talking I
just point out to viewers we're looking
at pictures coming in from Burlington
Virginia who might recall the story of
uh Vermont sorry where um Palestinian uh
uh students were attack that's one of
them who was is now being released from
hospital I I guess it underscores the
very real life and that's Hisham
awartani I should point out it
underscores the very real life
consequences that you were referring to
this isn't just happening on social
media the Council on American Islamic
relations care for example receiving
more than
2,000 requests for help and reports of
bias in just 57 days it says is this
creating a new Norm for islamophobia for
suppression of minorities
now well it's a continuation of what
we've been seeing for the last 22 years
I I I wrote an entire book about this
the racial Muslim when racism questiones
religious freedom which is how
islamophobia after 911 became became
normalized and mainstreamed and what
we're seeing is an expansion of
islamophobia to not just include people
who are Muslim Arab and South Asian but
also to include people within those
communities who defend the rights of
Palestinians or who just criticize the
human rights violations of Israel and
remember these are the same people who
also criticize the human rights
violations of Arab and Muslim majority
countries and they usually receive
rewards for that type of human rights
advocacy but when they uh when they
direct their human rights advocacy to
Israel suddenly they're slandered and
defamed as hateful and anti-semitic so
it goes to show that this is really
about um racism and it's against these
communities and it's also about
sensorship and I can't think of anything
more anti-American than not allowing for
the free flow of debate and discussion
about an issue in which our government
in the United States funds the state
$3.8 billion to Israel's military and
Biden just now ask Congress for 10
billion more dollars so this is exactly
what we should be discussing and
debating both sides of the issue but
what you're seeing is the media
politicians universities workplaces and
social media they only want the pro
Palestinian perspective to be uh
expressed all right thanks so much for
your analysis on that Sahar
aiz